what is going on guys so I am currently
in Los Angeles I went to the AFI Film
Festival and tonight I saw Jackie with
Natalie Portman and I'm sorry for the
very poor video and audio quality I was
not able to take my camera or microphone
on the plane with me this might actually
be the only review I do with the
festival in this format I just know that
as soon as I get home I'm going to have
to review fantastic beasts and where to
find them as well as a slew of other
films I'm seeing it the festival and I
don't want to rush those videos I don't
want to rush this video I want to give
the best reviews that I can but in doing
some while I'm here despite not having
my normal video and audio equipment
that'll give me a chance to do longer
reviews as some of the other films I'm
seeing and be able to focus on a little
bit more I've seen moonlight so far I'm
seeing lala land tomorrow and split and
tonight I saw Jackie which is the story
of Jackie Kennedy as portrayed by
Natalie Portman she has been recently
widowed this takes place directly after
her husband John F Kennedy was
assassinated in the car as she sat next
to him and it's the story of how she
dealt with that immediately what she
went through how she worked through it
in her mind her struggle with faith the
difficulties she faced in trying to
figure out if she wanted to stay in
politics how she wanted to honor her
husband's legacy whether or not there
should be a very public funeral or if it
should be more private because a lot of
people were afraid of more
assassinations more gunfire more
attempts at people's lives and so there
were a lot of emotions going through
people's minds at the time and this
movie captures that very well and easily
the best part of Jackie from me
personally was the acting this is
probably the best performance I've seen
from Natalie Portman since Black Swan I
think she fully inhabits this character
she was excellent in this role she gave
a very hardened sense of humanity that
I've never really seen from her before
she's very good at acting vulnerable
even in Black Swan which I still
consider her best performance she is
very vulnerable in that movie in this
film she's like a brick wall she feels
impenetrable and that was apparent in a
lot of scenes but there were also some
scenes where her character
opened up ever so slightly and you were
able to peer into her psyche a little
bit and understand what was going on and
most of those scenes are with John Hurt
who portrays a reverend that she goes to
for advice and those were some of my
favorite scenes in the movie because
they were the most emotionally open
scenes because she was away from people
because for most of the movies she's
just surrounded by her various political
advisors the scenes with John Hurt where
she was able to express her feelings a
little more openly I found those to be
the most compelling in the movie Peter
Sarsgaard is usually always good in
movies although he does have a habit of
kind of disappearing into the background
in films and he's pretty good as Bobby
Kennedy in this movie but you're not
gonna walk away going man Peter
Sarsgaard he really stole his show in
this one the focus here is definitely on
Natalie Portman but she is later
interviewed by a reporter played by
Billy Crudup Crudup Crudup I always mess
up his last name I thought he was
awesome Mook
this is probably the best movie about
Jackie Kennedy and how she dealt with
the days after that assassination that
we're ever going to see that being said
I do have issues with this movie and
well clearly the direction in regards to
working with actors was on point because
every actor is just in the moment
perfectly in this movie the performances
and the various moments and scenes that
are captured by the director are so well
done and you genuinely do feel like
you're appearing through the looking
glass into a time period the 60s are
captured extremely well it genuinely
feels like I am looking at the 60s and
they did a great job of recreating
various news archive footage to make it
feel like we were watching the original
tapes of certain things that being said
visually this isn't really a very pretty
movie to look at
despite Natalie Portman's beauty most of
the shots are framed kind of like what
I've done right now with my webcam just
perfectly centered and your eye doesn't
move a lot he doesn't do too much with
the left and right side of the frames
it's a very visually bland film in
regards to what he does with the camera
it feels almost documentarian esque
which for some people they're going to
love they're going to love that you
don't necessarily
notice the direction I like when a
director shows us things in a way we've
never seen them before and this film
doesn't feel that way it's a visually
drab movie there is much going on with
color it is a very depressing looking
movie which fix its story because these
are characters inhabiting a very
depressing time of their lives
but still I would have liked it to be
more visually interesting and less of
just everything perfectly centered all
the time in the end I think people are
going to watch Jackie for the
performances especially Natalie Portman
who might be nominated for an Oscar I
think she is excellent in this role but
in the long run I'm not seeing this
having very good replay value I'll
certainly never watch Jackie again as I
said it's probably the best film that
could be made about this story so great
performance is a compelling story the
scenes with John Hurt in which her
character really emotionally opened
herself those were I think the best in
the movie but for me personally I would
have liked to have seen a little more
style in the direction but for some
people that might actually be a plus
that this is more documentarian ask I'm
going to give a Jacki of B so guys well
in here at the AFI festival you guys are
having a good time I'm going to be
seeing a lot more movies as I said I'm
going to have reviews for a lot of
interesting as I get home this will
probably be one of only a couple if not
the only very low-quality video you're
going to get again I apologize for that
but as always guys you are the best
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes